From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
Hi. I'm John Brown.
In this edition of the
BARD Mobile How-To Series,
we are going to cover activating
and deactivating VoiceOver
in iOS devices.
VoiceOver is a full-featured screen
reader available on all iOS devices
that run the BARD Mobile
application.
It allows blind users to access
iPhones, iPods, and iPads.
To turn VoiceOver on,
go to Settings.
From there, select
General, then Accessibility.
Under the heading Vision,
select VoiceOver.
Slide the on/off switch to On.
Note that gestures for
navigating the device are different
when VoiceOver is turned on.
Once you have activated VoiceOver,
triple clicking the Home button
on your device will quickly
turn VoiceOver on and off.
A blind user may turn VoiceOver
on without sighted assistance
by connecting the device
to a computer
and accessing it through iTunes.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.